being i mean are you going to miss this
show like hell you're going to miss i
could tell you're already missing
i've cried every day for a week you
really you genuinely cry
yeah i read the script every day um
and even just moments on set you know we
have where
we're filming our last episode so every
now and again we're at a location it's
like oh i've been here 15 years i
remember this place i remember where
i played my dog and this and that and
it's like okay this is the last time
we'll be at this location
and i think to myself there's a
possibility i'm trying to be aware of
but i'll never make this drive again we
just shot um kind of
up city sky highway uh last week and on
the drive down it was our last day at
that location
and i was like oh my god like i might
never make this drive again i hope i do
i hope i do but i'm just preparing
myself to go like i might never see this
and i you know i would go to whistler on
weekends and go skiing or go hiking or
whatever the
season was um i'm really excited it's
very bittersweet
and apples and i talk every day about it
and
it's long days you know we have to
finish what we have to finish we don't
have any pickup shots
it's not like hey we'll come back in a
month because what the quarantine for
two more weeks
and it doesn't make sense uh financially
did they schedule the last
very last final moment between you and
jensen
together so you're in the last shot
before you both rap at the same time
is that what's gonna happen i'll say
this
i'm trying to figure out the i'm saying
like ask two actors because they shoot
out of order are you guys going to be
together on the final take of the final
day
the last time sam and dean see each
other is the last time jared and jensen
see each other if that makes any sense
i'm not saying what the last scene is
going to be but the last
moment i have on camera with jensen and
vice versa will be the last
filming moment i have on camera with
jensen and how
emotional i could just see two of you
good-looking [ __ ] just
bawling together oh my god sweating you
got the sauna
you guys got the sauna blanket over both
of you you're just crying your [ __ ]
eyes out
here it's already been emotional man you
know what's funny is that um
is that he and i both and you know this
you worked with him and you know me for
a long time and
he and i both are so committed to these
characters you know he plays dean
rochester i play san manchester
like i love sam winchester he's been my
close friend for 15 years
and i want to do him justice so i'm
focusing really hard
i'm trying to focus really hard to make
sure that if sam cries it's sam tears
not jared's
like at my heart like it wasn't
necessarily that i want to be famous or
i want to be in a
jbot magazine or whatever i want to tell
stories
and i want to tell sam's story and i i
did a christmas movie of season one
with uh you know jason ciccini yeah of
course yeah thomas
he's he's my dear dear friend and i hope
he comes down to austin
but um uh he did the move with me and
there was a scene i had with peter
o'toole who's one of my
and i i so badly wanted to impress him
and press the director
that i ended up getting to a place where
i kept crying after they called cut
and peter was like michael to the
director he's like can can jared and i
have a moment
and mike was like absolutely so he told
everybody to take 10 minutes and go get
the crafty or something
and peter o'toole comes with me and says
hey
that was wonderful that was phenomenal
those are tom's tears i played a card
named thomas kincaid
tom and so he's like those are tom's
tears don't steal them
save them for tom and from a guy who
like went to radha
you know eight-time oscar nominee i'm
not lawrence of arabia
my favorite year like he i was like i'll
be damned like what a great
what a great thing and he was 80 at the
time i was 23 or 24
um and he is he is peter o'toole and i
was like what a cool thing to say like
remember
i'm glad you got there that was
wonderful those aren't your tears
when they call action if tom cries give
them to him wow
just like a little thing that just went
so oh you were like
i've had that and it's always from
veteran actors john glover
um i don't yes i can i don't know what's
going on john can't
like uh well just listen to me just
let's do let's just talk let's just
just it's just me and you it's your [ __ ]
it's your dad and i looked at him i go
oh my god roll cameras i got it
and then i go and i just listen now i'm
like what i forgot to listen
you